More disappointing behavior
yesterday coming
from America's least profitable
investment-- our schools.
An estimated one million
students took part
in Wednesday's national school
walkout against gun violence.
They mobilized at schools
from coast to coast,
demanding that Congress
and state lawmakers do more
-to restrict access to guns.
-(indistinct chanting)
Oh, now you're making demands,
huh, kids? What's next?
We all have to eat sloppy joes
for lunch every day?
I'm a grown up.
I eat clean, tidy josephs.
Frankly, I tried to ignore
all these protests,
which is why I was reassured
when I tuned into Infowars
and saw Scott Adams--
yes, Dilbert cartoonist,
Scott Adams--
explain why these students
deserve to be ignored.
There are very few people
among the young
who are leaving school today,
who would actually even claim
to having a good knowledge
of the entire gun debate,
you know,
all of the elements of it,
enough to really have a,
you know, a reasoned opinion.
The people who were doing
the protesting
are the dumbest members
of society.
Yes. Scott Adams knows dumb
when he sees it.
He spent 28 years drawing a guy
who can't iron his (bleep) tie.
Now, Adams made
an excellent point,
which is that gun control
is a nuanced, complex debate,
and these kids aren't nearly
knowledgeable enough to know
that they don't want
to be shot.
They're just too dumb
to weigh-in.
That's why you need an expert.
And what do experts say
when it comes to gun control?
They almost universally
push the narrative
that gun control saves lives,
which is why
we can't trust experts.
Okay, so you can't trust kids,
and you can't trust experts.
'Cause kids are too dumb.
Experts are too elitist.
So who can you trust?
The middle.
A confident
television personality
with great hair and
a limited frame of reference,
just like Laura Ingraham.
We're talking
about students here.
And for anyone who takes
the time to look
at our academic standing
in the world,
students need more academics,
more classroom time,
not more hysterics.
Exactly, Laura.
That's why the U.S.
is trailing in academics.
The kids keep walking out
to protest
every school shooting,
so they're never in school.
And teachers don't have time
to catch them up,
because the president sent them
all off to target practice.
The bottom line is,
true patriots understand
that if you want to protest,
there's only one right way.
TIM:
Our parochial school teachers
worked with the students
and put together
a pro-program of a walk-in.
And they went into the churches
and auditoriums,
and recognized, um,
the victims with prayer.
I really like that.
Think about that.
Commemorating the lost,
remembering the victims.
Prayer offered as a class.
To me, that makes a lot more
sense than yelling into
a microphone in front
of some government building.
Yeah, she's right.
Yelling into a microphone
outside of a government building
never affects government change.
Take it from me
and my wheelbarrow
of parking tickets.
Sure, if you want to raise
a stink about something,
you could dominate a full day
of cable news coverage
with a nationwide protest.
Or you could quietly whisper
your hopes and dreams
into your closed palms,
where only Jesus can hear them.